irgendwo auf den unfall bei google maps
api ist ein typ im mülleimer leute wollt
ihr mich verarschen
hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video ich habe
mich einfach mal gefragt ja es gibt bei
google maps so unfassbar viele orte und
die komplette welt ist eigentlich nahezu
damit abgedeckt wenn man eine straße
finden möchte findet man die straße wenn
man haus nehmen möchte findet man das
haus wenn man leute finden möchte werden
auch teilweise leute abgebildet aber hey
wenn da so viel abgebildet ist muss da
doch jeden was total bescheuerten witzig
verrücktes auch abgebildet sein und ja
das habe ich gefunden meine damen und
herren und zwar bin ich auf dieser
website hier gelandet das ist nämlich
hacker riet
ich glaube ich nicht wie heißt von ecri
peace train stift irving google street
view images das heißt wir werden jetzt
vielleicht nicht alle durchgehen aber
jetzt mal relativ viele von diesen
bildern uns mal anschauen okay das ist
finde ich jetzt sogar noch nicht mal so
creepy da ist einfach irgendeine figur
in schwarz irgendwie auf einem balkon
gestellt worden und da stehen halt
drüber krines overload von franz aber
ich finde es jetzt nicht so krass
eigentlich hier stehen zwei leute in
irgendwelchen kitteln und hier ist
irgendwie so ein komischer professor
irgend so eine maschine aufgefordert
hier laufen anscheinend aliens über
einen bürgersteig oder die haben einfach
schlecht sind für kleidung alter hier
ist einfach so ein alter mann auf einem
verlassenen weg und steht dort einfach
mit deiner tasche romig teile euch mal
vor ihr vater mit dem fahrrad oder zu
fuß lang und geht auch treffen diesen
mann auf dem verlassenen weg und er
steht also ganz allein hat das mega
creepy dieses bild trägt die überschrift
freunde half men weil der typ hat
verfolgen boden steht aber das ist
allgemein mega oft sobald so google maps
beiträgen bzw sachen die wenn man sich
das anschaut vor allem bei street view
dass das so voll verzerrt ist und da
sind seine leute in der oberkörper ist
hier und der unterkörper irgendwie hier
vorne oder so
hier haben die genau mit gehilfen apps
auf einer straße gerade gefilmt wo ein
typ geholt hat weil er irgendwie unfall
hat mit seiner karre no idea what car
hin und hier ist die bezeichnung von
diesem bild wo leute und jagen mit mir
gegenüber spedition haben die türken
wird sondern über die sitze und geatmet
menschen und wird ihr wagen die das
google maps ist eine prostituierte
einfach am straßenrand falls sich wieso
das so lustig ich denke wer einfach nur
so gut ist einfach so ein service der
ultras ist das alles hinzukriegen
mussten ja quasi mit der karte quasi
durch die komplette welt fahren
diese zwei leute jagen die für paare als
wäre das irgend so ein riesiger wal den
die gerade beim tauchen effekt haben so
wie übrigens wieder für bad hair day
aber irgendwie sind in letzter zeit alle
tage wird hair days weil ich meine haare
länger wachsen lassen möchte und die
gehen mir gerade bis ich hier also die
sind halt schon so lang eigentlich aber
ich wollte einfach mal was ausprobieren
und warum kämpft ihr alter hier ist
irgendwie dieses google maps auto wohl
durch eine stadt am meer her gefahren
und es einfach eine möwe und fliegt so
sein knapper tiefparterre vorbei
überschrift hier soll es einfach sammler
ex also irgendwo aus dem fenster ragen
einfach keine raus nähe der hat sich ein
junge versteckt vor der karre
ich weiß aber mit irgendeinem kumpel
verstecken gespielt hat oder nicht bei
google maps drin sein wollte aber das
hat nicht so ganz geklappt hinterhöfen
für die frau versucht die karte besteht
die da und oder sie grüßt ich weiß nicht
sie winkte hinzu das kann auch sein
umgehen da sind mädels louis
die hagenower ist ein typ im mülleimer
leute wollt ihr mich verarschen die
überschrift von dem ticket auch so
partie in der trash can really have no
idea what s up to ist bettencourt an
kamera also da hat wohl diese google
dingens genau gefilmt als hinten ein
oder bisschen mehr genauen foto gemacht
wohin ein blitz irgendwo eingeschlagen
ist das krass hier ist ein blitz ins
auto eingeschlagen
da steht ein halbnackter kommen ziehen
in brüssel also die leute haben gesagt
hat dass gerade einen diebstahl ist ja
eigentlich im gange ist aber das ist
eigentlich eine 1 1 1 1
das ist das ist ein kenner hier kämpfen
zwei holz
das ist doch nicht paar was für eine
scheiße gibt es bei google maps man das
hier ist leider nicht witzig und zwar
liegt da einfach ne kuh also ich weiß
das liegt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
lustig aus aber entweder ist die kuh
halt krank und kann nicht mehr laufen
oder sie ich weiß nicht keine ahnung
aber schon krass dass das die dass das
einfach alles bei google maps ist wo ich
komme da überhaupt nicht darauf klar wir
schauen uns jetzt mal die nächste sache
gleich bei google maps an und zwar ist
sie irgendwo auch den unfall live bei
google maps auf hin dass hier sieht mir
nach england aus und zwar liegt hier ein
besoffener typ du bist auch live bei
google maps kann sogar an zoom hammer
wusstest du dich bei google maps trendig
dass wir sind zwei punks das von youtube
und die haben hier so ein todesfall
beziehungsweise eine mörder aktion
vorgetäuscht einfach nur um popularität
auf google maps
an sich zu reissen sage ich mal aber es
hat auf jeden fall geklappt ich mein
held ich gucke mir an und machen wie die
heute hatte ich weiß nicht was die
beiden hier gemacht haben aber irgendwie
sieht aus wie eine mischung aus breaking
bad und golf spielen mit irgendwelchen
komischen anzügen dass wir hier haben
weiß ich nicht er hat mich einfach
irgendwo hierhin gesetzen ich weiß nicht
was hier super sein soll an diesem ding
aber
hmm
ein schöner strand in der tat hier haben
fachleute ein komplettes haus mit
klopapier überzogen beziehungsweise
eingedeckt und das ist auch live auf
google maps festgehalten worden das sind
einfach leute die sich eine tauben maske
aufgesetzt haben warum was tut ihr das
was bringt euch das hier ist einfach ein
tiger degas einfach in der in der freien
dings in tiger tiger diese frau macht
einfach yoga mit einer straße auf einer
grünen wiese also soll sie machen aber
jeder kann er dabei zugucken über sich
eine sexpuppe gekauft alles klar
die mögen glaube ich google street view
nicht weil die dem die ganze zeit
mittelfinger zu stecken er bekommt
gerade einen blowjob das ist auf jeden
fall live gold das bei google maps drin
zu haben er pinkelt einfach neben seinem
auto egal warum da ist eine wand da ist
irgendwo eine ecke vielleicht an der
wand da kannst du auch gegen pinkeln
aber doch nicht neben dein auto was was
soll das jetzt hypoport stellt euch mal
vor ihr seid bei google maps drehen und
popeln oder sowie wie nüchtern wäre das
denn hier haben wir wieder ein unfall
aber an übelsten unfall diesmal alter
okay das ist das ist krass hier hat
einer mitten in public also mitten in
der öffentlichkeit einen job bekommen
also diese frau hat ihn irgendwie einen
runtergeholt ich weiß auch nicht wieso
man das allgemein in der öffentlichkeit
macht leute mit einer knarre ok live auf
google maps leute mit einer knarre super
amerika hat die polizei gerade irgendwen
festgenommen und der liegt hinten drin
auf dem auf dem pk da ist ein alpaka
ich könnte heulen in alpaka bei google
maps einfach so mitten im alten typen
vor dem dings hier hat einfach einen
mann in seinem auto geknackt sein hund
liegt davor ist in ordnung leute das ist
einfach wirklich nur creed ii die haben
masken auf die stehen irgendwo in der
wildnis und das ist einfach nur creepy
die leute vögeln einfach was ist denn
mit euch los dass ihr das alles so in
der öffentlichkeit machen musste habt
ihr gab die kein zuhause oder so da
hättet ihr wenigstens ins auto geben
können hier hat ein kind eine waffe und
richtet sie auf einen mann ich meine
egal ob fake waffe oder richtige waffe
aber es sieht echt aus wie eine krimi
szene gerade hier ist ein baby einfach
verloren gegangen bitte einfach um von
gucci store nahe sie ist hingefallen oh
gott und allen direkt schnell um hilfe
er zeigt einfach so ein arsch
ist in ordnung halber leistung alter die
wurden festgenommen bin live auf google
maps stellt euch mal vor die eltern
sehen das oder so okay das ist das ist
jetzt sicher dass das 50.000 bild wo
irgend eine prostituierte da ist oder
das irgendwie gleich was man es mit sex
zu tun hat deswegen würde ich sagen an
dieser stelle das was hier familie meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
lassen manfred liegt da denn nicht sowas
nochmal machen soll schreibt sowohl in
die kommentare was hat euch am meisten
verblüfft dass das bei google maps war
schreibt mir das auf jeden fall auch mal
unten in die kommentare und schreibt man
bitte jetzt auch einfach mal google maps
in die kommentare ich weiß ich muss
gerade eine menge in die kommentare
schreiben aber ich wollte einfach mal
schauen wer das video wirklich bis zum
ende geschaut hat und wie viele das sind
von dem prozent an zuschauern blablabla
einfach um mich noch vom schmidt weiter
zu verbessern et cetera pp hier findet
ihr einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf könnte meinen kanal abonnieren
das kostenlos und nehmen automatisch am
gewinnspiel teil wo ihr eine nintendo
3ds l die xl dem was gewinnen können
hier findet irgendwie die eingeblendet
also ist bestimmt auch hinten kackt
wieder kriegt da drauf auf beides am
besten